so what's the difference between joy and
love
michael malus uh i think joy is easier
to attain
it's more common you could share it with
everyone
give me an example of joy like what was
a moment of joy for you recently
i could give you a great example of joy
and this is part in the absurdist
mindset
okay i love having a bad meal at a
restaurant
and i'll give you you can see why you go
with your friend
it takes you 45 minutes to get seated
okay
i'm starving waiters not at paying
attention to you yeah they bring your
water it's got a hair in it
they get the food wrong yeah it comes
out again it's ripe but it's cold
at a certain point you're like okay i'm
hungry
i'm living an anecdote this is something
that you
if you were at dinner we could talk
about this for years because
how great is it that the worst thing
that's happening to me
is i gotta wait an hour for this meal
that's gonna be cooked wrong
right that to me is joy is holding on
to that idea that happiness and thriving
are possible
even when in the moment it's uh
everything's going the wrong way doesn't
every moment have the capacity to uh
fill you with joy then yes so yes the
shitty moments and the good moments yes
but that
see that's the way i usually talk about
love is like
i love life yes and in
because life can generate every
everything the pain
the loss but also just like
simple or complicated bliss all of that
i just love all of that and that because
it fills me with it with a kind of
i guess joy but joy has a connotation
that is supposed to be somehow positive
like you're supposed to be smiling
uh to me you know man search for meaning
with victor
frankel you know just it's you're
you're in the holocaust you're in a
concentration camp
just having a little bit of food that
you didn't expect you will have
uh or even just thinking about food or
what about there's a kid there you tell
them a funny story and you crack them up
yeah like you take away this child's
pain for like five minutes that is the
height of joy
yeah so to me like all of like life is
like
infinitely full of possibility for joy
yes and that's what i mean by love
because
oftentimes like romantic love is what
people
think about when they think love but to
me it's all like part of the same thing
and it's almost like love romantic love
or
love with a friend friendship is like
you both notice each other it's like
dogs they look at each other and then
they look at the thing they're
interested in you both notice each other
and
that moment of joy you share that moment
of joy together yeah like the restaurant
yeah the restaurant
yeah if you're both almost without
uh conspiring notice the
absurdity of how shitty this meal is and
like that again that little glimmer of
realization
that's that's what makes life beautiful
you